let f be a twice differentiable function
one of these graphs is the graph of f
one is of f prime and one is of the
second derivative of f f prime prime
match each function with its appropriate
graph so i encourage you to pause the
video and try to figure out which of
these is f which of these is f prime and
which of these is f prime prime
all right now let's work through this
together
so there's a couple of ways to think
about it
one way to think about it is if these
were graphs of polynomials
the then f would be a higher degree
polynomial so you have
f if you were to take the derivative of
that you would get to f prime so this
derivative with respect to x and if you
take the derivative with respect to x of
that you get f prime prime so whatever
degree polynomial this is if it is a
polynomial this will be a lower degree
and then this would be an even lower
degree polynomial so let's see if we can
make sense of these graphs using that
lens
well one way to think about it is higher
degree polynomials are going to have
more minima or more potential minimum or
maximum points and it looks like b here
has the most minima and maxima a has the
second most and then c has the third
most so my first hypothesis is that
what we have right over here b that this
is the graph of f
that a
is the graph of f prime and that c is
the graph of the second derivative f
prime prime
so that's just my hypothesis now let's
see if it actually makes sense
and what i can do is i can look at
points where i know that the derivative
would be zero and then look at the
derivative to confirm or what i think is
the derivative to confirm that they are
and then i could also look at trends
so let's say if this is f so once again
that was just my initial guess that this
is going to be the function f so let's
see i have a slope of 0 a slope of a
tangent line of 0 right over there
so slope of 0 right over there
i have a slope of 0
right over there i have a slope of 0
right over there i have a slope of 0 a
horizontal tangent line
right over there
so let's see if this is the derivative
then this function should be equal to
zero at this x value this x value this x
value and this x value because the slope
of the tangent line at those x values
looks like zero
so this function is equal to zero here
here
here and here
well these seem to coincide
this coincides with this
this coincides with that
and that coincides with that and then
that coincides with that so i'm already
feeling pretty good about it
so now let's see if this f prime prime
what i think is f prime prime is indeed
the derivative of f prime
so it's got a minimum point right over
here it looks like the slope of the
tangent line here is zero let me do this
in a different color
so this
looks like we have a slope of zero there
it looks like we have a slope of zero
right over there and looks like we have
a slope of zero
right
over there so that point
for that x value that x value and that x
value and we see that this function is
indeed equal to zero right over here
right over here and right over here at
the exact same x values so based on what
i just said i would feel pretty good if
i was under time pressure i already feel
pretty good about how i match things up
but you could also look at trends
between points so for a example
let me pick out a trend so between
this
between this maximum point and this
minimum point at first the slope is
decreasing
so the slope is getting more and more
negative and you see from here to here
is indeed getting more and more negative
and then it starts getting more and more
positive starting right about here so
that trend seems to be consistent and so
you could look for these trends as well
but i find looking at the minimum and
maximum where you see
horizontal tangent lines or where the
slope of the tangent line is zero those
are the easiest to test for your
derivatives or your second derivatives